what's up guys we're punk finiti today
we're playing a petting whole tournament
let's see who else
so the panel group is the traditional
Chinese table tennis prick so you
basically hold the racket like a pen
first much me versus enemy let's go to
be honest I think I'm gonna lose this
one well I think so too sir
good luck
oh I think I spell moved up it better
about butter once
whoo this is going pretty well yeah I
remember I have said that before to
Europe and I lost all the points on
I'm giving you a head start
[Music]
they'll giving a head start
steel steel I have to give you one point
thanks
[Music]
all right like a side spin I don't know
you don't know what to write
no now you started playing it y-yeah I
had whoa thank you
the chop block didn't quite work I won't
miss stuff anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
know what am i doing
I came too close and I wasn't like
should I think good backhand or forehand
[Music]
that was good
[Music]
that wasn't supposed to go even though
it wasn't haha zero zero
[Music]
oh I tried to set you up for a little
counter smash oh my Serbs aren't exactly
the same as normal
Oh hide it with a finger right yep
[Applause]
hello oh sorry
Houston it oh I'm just trying to hurt
the ml there clearly yes
[Music]
I expected you to go around the net Oh
stiff whoa oh it's good
safe shots
this much I was a bit like trapped in
here
luckily very common table
[Music]
yes No
[Music]
I'm sure what I was waiting Thanks
[Music]
well yeah you have a package
I'm really sorry that's that's the only
way you're gonna win this match more of
those I need all this anymore
yeah I would see my good server yes
bring it I'm sorry it's gonna laugh
you're laughing now by 99 when I ripped
that back hand on anyone see who's
laughing huh you kind of left real it's
good to have three of us in their life
just put it back in ah you serious
oh he's serious he's serious looking
jumping
come on high five three
Oh Oh that was like the streamer guy
yeah it's kind of the same come on oh
good rally look boys yeah okay and it's
gone down a bit I've nothing out for
this excited me neither I have to give
it to you that was a good shot
[Music]
I should've just kept pushing like
autism I said I was gonna calm down
that means pushing yeah I'm so sorry ah
whoa that's it over
[Music]
this is much in stake in this match as
the 500k subscribers is more this is
even more I miss there it would have
been so perfect I get to see new mr.
back Harrison I would I'm gonna route to
net back and South right
yeah
oh well we've got that match point match
points since that's gonna lose this one
yes when I lose that one never even had
a chance
how does it how does it feel to be
beaten not the good yeah you know nice
nice change being always on top it's
foreign mentally yeah yeah mentally so
it's good to use sometimes to keep your
life balance yeah so you're not used to
it keeps you in the crunch but yeah yeah
so that you're not too good yep yeah
exactly
and also this relieves some pressure so
you don't have to keep winning
everything yeah
let us know which tournaments you want
to see next and don't forget to hit
subscribe and watch our previous
episodes there until next time